back here in the channel 8 phone bank
and today we're answering your questions
about medicare enrollment as this is the
annual enrollment period continuing my
conversation with scott hanson who is
the sales director for united healthcare
this is a there's a window of time where
people can take care of this whether
they're enrolled now and want to change
their plan or
this may be their first time yeah that's
correct kendall
choosing a medicare plan is so important
and december 7th is the date we want to
make sure that people are making a good
educated decision prior to december 7th
to take a look at their current plan
make sure that it best fits their needs
or think about moving to ad benefits or
change to a new plan that might be a
better fit for both their health needs
and their pocketbook
you mentioned before some resources
where people can get information of
course they can call here today
702-650-1101
or there are some websites they can
check out that's correct i want to make
sure i get this right so i'm going to
refer to my paper here
unitedhealthcareplans.com it's great
resource and also get to know
medicare.com what are some of the big
obstacles that you see people running
into when they're searching for that
right plan yeah we would we want to make
sure that people are thinking about
their current plan prior to their call
that actually will help our team help
them there are three things that we
would like them to consider the first
thing is their current plan and does it
still fit their medical and their
budgets
the second thing is um
their their drug coverage is their
current plan a good fit for their drug
coverage and finally is it a good fit
for their budget there are so many plans
out there with additional added values
that they may not be seeing today on
their current plan and really briefly as
we have about 10 seconds there are some
ways and some ideas to stay healthy
amidst everything that's going on that
you can take advantage of through your
medicare plan there definitely are with
covet 19 we understand that people may
have concerns about going in person and
seeing their provider
we make it easy with uh opportunities
like telehealth excellent scott hansen
thank you we'll be here throughout the
evening to answer your questions
phone number once again 702-650-1111
those phone lines will be open until
seven tonight we'll be